you know I hear a lot of people say Pat
I worked 20 hours yesterday well I'm a 4
a.m. ER I'm a 5 a.m. er and I look at
him I say you post all this stuff about
how hard you work how come you haven't
won yet it's not accidental there's a
reason why you haven't won yet it's not
like oh my gosh I'm not winning because
things aren't happening for me there's a
formula for success you see if you were
to measure someone's hardest working day
versus another person's hardest working
day let's just say this person is
extremely successful and you had a
twenty hour work day that part's very
close the part where they win is their
bottom 100 worse working days of the
year
crush everybody else's bottom worse 100
working days of the year let me explain
to you on this side the person that
works 20 hours works 20 hours because he
watched a movie they got motivated after
rocky or they watched and watch this
video on YouTube I'm so jacked up I saw
this motivational thing was sick man
this 30-30 I listened to Tupac yesterday
I am lit up I'm gonna take over the
world for one day maybe two days maybe
three days well this guy's saying I'm
gonna show up every single day and show
you what real workers do he shows up on
his birthday
he shows up the day after Thanksgiving
the day before Thanksgiving the day
after Christmas the day before Christmas
morning Christmas he'll come and work
six hours then he'll go and celebrate
with the family those are the days that
they crush everybody else so now the
challenge to use this sheet of paper
make a list
what are your bottom worse 100 working
days of the last 12 months then measure
your success against everybody else who
wins at the highest level
you
[Music]